the game of thrones in general as a game
of cronyism because it's all about
forming political alliances especially
with people who can make you better off
economically speaking I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer fries in TV and today we're
talking with Matt McCaffrey he's an
instructor at Auburn University and a
fellow at the Mises Institute Matt
thanks for talking to us thank you for
having me so you've written about Game
of Thrones lately and economics and
politics that go along with the book
series as well as the HBO series and we
all love Game of Thrones for the sex
action and gore but I think part of what
makes it so engaging is that the
politics and economics connect the realm
to reality if you talk about how there
are some historical underpinnings to the
economic system George Martin when he
writes his books he actually does a lot
of historical research to try and get
the the tone and the feeling of the sort
of medieval setting right and to do that
apparently he does a lot of research
into sort of the more economic aspects
of how simply just how you run a kingdom
or in his case Seven Kingdoms maybe as
part of his process he ends up sort of
uncovering a lot of historical details
that would usually get lost in a fantasy
book of this kind just practical
difficulties with of running a kingdom
how public finance works how the game of
thrones corrupts the people who play it
and how it ends disastrously for the
people who don't play it well whoever
sitting on the throne they figure out
that there's three ways to control the
states financers borrowing taxation and
inflation so and I think they use all
three of these can you talk about
borrowing first and how especially in
times of war this is particularly
relevant yeah well this is a huge
problem for the Lannisters especially as
they attempt to finance this seemingly
endless war against all the the other
they would like to believe pretenders to
the throne so what they have to do is of
course war is extremely expensive and so
they borrow heavily usually from foreign
banks from the so-called Free Cities
we're sort of off on the sidelines in
the story but of course they find out
very quickly that borrowing is extremely
difficult especially if there's a risk
that you're not going to be paying back
your loans and of course all the the
foreign banks are very worried that
they're going to lose the
or and so they may charge exorbitantly
high rates of interest and it becomes
increasingly difficult for the liner's
just to pay back their debts one of
their other chosen methods of public
finance is coin clipping this is a
practice that goes back long before the
mid of the Middle Ages actually but it
was particularly popular in the Middle
Ages and it's a process of inflating the
money supply by debasing the coinage and
so the Lannisters are behind the scenes
especially Littlefinger the master of
coin is engaged in this activity and is
actually increasing the money supply by
producing debased coins Circe says at
one point that she wishes they just had
a bank of Lannister is there anything to
be taken from that I definitely think so
because the drive to produce a central
bank is of course one of the the logical
economic outcomes of the government
finance they continually need new
sources of finance because you can't tax
people forever you can't borrow forever
then your third option is to create
money and especially to create a central
bank that you can use to to finance your
activities and that's what the
Lannisters want to do we do see a lot of
cases of Taxation even sin taxes to pay
for Joffrey's lavish wedding this tax is
what they call the the dwarfs penny and
it's a tax on prostitution that the
Lannisters enact because they have many
shrewd taxation strategies where they
for things like sin taxes where they
they can be reasonably sure that the
demand for the product will be stable
and more broadly speaking I mean this is
sort of the epitome of cronyism do you
see any other examples of that well of
course the game of thrones in general is
a game of cronyism because it's all
about forming political alliances
especially with people who can make you
better off economically speaking so for
example in the recent season we've seen
an alliance between the Lannisters and
the Tyrells the Tyrells are one of the
most economically powerful families and
so now they're trying to to curry favor
with the crown and at the same time even
before the Lannisters were in control
you have someone like Tywin Lannister
who's a very wealthy man who is
financing basically all of the Crown's
activities when Robert Baratheon is king
and it's very clear that there's an
exchange being made there that Tywin
Lannister has real control as a
steering their government simply through
his power as as a financier do we ever
see an example of capitalism and it
prevailing it's interesting because you
do have what are called the free cities
which are a group of cities that are not
on the the central continent and some of
them are our slaves cities so they're
actually the opposite of free but some
of them do appear to be sort of thriving
commercial centers there's a lot of
trade going on carth would be an example
of this as a city that appeared in the
second season of the television show it
seems to be at least free relative to
some of the the kingdoms in Westeros and
they do seem to to thrive based on their
economic success Matt thanks so much no
one's thank you again for having me
reasontv I'm Tracy Oppenheimer